En este video voy a presentar dos unidades de
medidas de longitud. La primera es la pulgada,
de la que probablemente ya han oído, y tal vez
estén pensando "¿Cuánto mide una pulgada?" Bueno,
si estás familiarizado con un cuarto -que es la
moneda de veinticinco centavos estadounidense-,
un cuarto se ve así, tiene la imagen de George
Washington. Un cuarto mide casi una pulgada,
así que una pulgada podría ser algo así:
una pulgada. Otra forma de pensar en esto
es que mi pulgar -soy una mujer adulta, al menos
físicamente-, mi pulgar mide aproximadamente dos
pulgadas de largo, 1 pulgada, 2 pulgadas; va a
depender de tu edad. Si estás viendo este video,
y digamos que tienes 7 u 8 años, tu pulgar podría
estar más cerca de una pulgada o tal vez un poco
más de una pulgada. Ahora, la otra unidad de
medida la puedes ver como un conjunto de pulgadas,
y si pones 12 pulgadas juntas obtienes lo que se
conoce como un pie, 1 pie. La palabra "pie" se usa
para muchas cosas en nuestro idioma, incluso para
nuestros pies o lo que tenemos en los extremos de
nuestras piernas. Y no estoy segura de dónde
proviene esta unidad de medida, pero creo que
podrían estar relacionados, porque en realidad el
pie de un hombre mide casi un pie, unos zapatos de
hombre de talla 10 y medio miden casi exactamente
un pie. A veces puedes verlo como ft, que es la
abreviatura de la palabra pie en inglés. Ahora,
claramente no todos los pies miden exactamente un
pie, porque los pies y los zapatos de todos tienen
diferentes longitudes, pero eso te da una idea de
qué tan grande es un pie. Otra forma de pensar
en eso, y como acabo de mencionar, si juntas 12
pulgadas obtienes 1 pie, 12 pulgadas = 1 pie. Voy
a presentarles algunos objetos y quiero que pausen
el video y piensen si los medirían en pies o
en pulgadas, o si parece que las medidas están
en pies o en pulgadas. Así que si les doy una
hoja de papel, una hoja de papel normal, con sus
agujeros y sus bonitas líneas, y les dijera que
la altura es de 11 algo, ¿serían 11 pulgadas u
11 pies? Bueno, si fueran 11 pies sería una gran
hoja de papel, sería un papel más alto que yo;
parecería más una alfombra que una hoja, de modo
que una hoja de papel en realidad, una hoja de
papel estándar, mide 11 pulgadas de alto. Ahora,
si saliéramos a jugar un poco de basquetbol,
digamos que este es el tablero, y tenemos el aro y
la red, y luego tenemos el poste que los sostiene,
y este es un aro de basquetbol estándar de la
NBA; si dijera que está a 10 algo del suelo,
¿serían 10 pulgadas o 10 pies? Bueno, si fueran
10 pulgadas sería muy fácil anotar una canasta,
aunque podría ser difícil meter el balón en un
aro tan pequeño, eso sería más bien un aro de
basquetbol para algún insecto o para un ratón muy
pequeño. Para los seres humanos la altura estándar
del tablero de basquetbol con el que juegan en
la NBA es de 10 pies. Si eres un poco más joven,
es posible que en tu escuela veas un tablero de
basquetbol que mida 6 pies u 8 o 9 pies de alto,
pero la altura oficial de los tableros para los
profesionales es de 10 pies de alto. Ahora déjenme
mencionar algunas cosas, y quiero decidir si es
mejor medirlos con pies o con pulgadas. Digamos
que tengo una alberca justo aquí, esta es la
alberca, ¿sería mejor medir la longitud de la
alberca en pies o en pulgadas? Pausen el video y
piénsenlo. Bueno, una alberca es bastante grande,
es mucho más grande que un pie, así que si
tuviéramos que elegir entre pies y pulgadas para
medirlo, pensaríamos en usar pies. En este caso
la alberca podría ser de 75 pies de largo. Ahora,
si estuviéramos midiendo la longitud de un
ratón -no es mi mejor dibujo de un ratón;
esa es su cola, sus pies están justo aquí-,
¿sería mejor medirlo en pies o en pulgadas? Es
un ratón pequeño, un ratón que podría caber en tu
mano. Bueno, va a ser bastante menor que un pie,
entonces tiene sentido medirlo en pulgadas. He
visto ratones que pueden medir sólo dos o tres
pulgadas de largo. Lo dejaré aquí. Espero que
esto les dé una idea aproximada de lo que es una
pulgada, lo que es un pie, cómo se relacionan
entre sí y cuándo podrías usar uno u otro.